we are back baby Skyblock part 2
where's your monstrosity of a
cobblestone generator someone pushed you
off wait that was me so now we have to
race how do we do it I can't we can't
remake that but this time we do it and
we do it right Ken look I kept telling
your life SEPA sewed the ice make the
water flow we gotta go down see right
here you broke the extra block no it
needs to be one in between you smacker
yeah yeah yeah perfect yeah that took us
17 minutes last episode 17 but don't
forget that we said how to do it right
the very start of the whole video it
just took us 24 I actually some some
kids recognize me and they were like
where did you post your sky block I'm
like you want more of that I was like do
you have it like if so how to make a
cobblestone generator and then they were
like I don't know I'm like okay cool no
one actually nobody actually knows they
just like now now we make here you get
one pickaxe - oh yes senpai let's mine
the freaked out of this yeah I don't
know why I thought it would wake up with
two of us that makes enough yeah thank
you for for me we're speedrunning this
there you go alright yeah
can she believe a Smee but here takes a
kit what what's wrong would have to
invent new swear words because minecraft
well you start using the word flip what
the flip can't dig the dirt you know
that'd be bad okay don't like craps down
to pick this up or something
oh my god you're still back I am okay
well I can't ever pick up stuff I won't
burn myself a lot you can get like the
right spot you know this is like an art
okay wait I'll do it I'll do it because
I think it's easier for me to grab them
yeah I guess yeah
the desync that's what I blame anybody
using the using the precious dirt to
make a bridge right now are you serious
I need I need a baby are you serious I
need you using the dirt right now we
need to get back to where we were when
we get over there we're gonna have to
like make a farm or something we I can't
believe you right now like am I crazy
but I think our cobblestone generator
was actually better it was weirdly
enough you could actually catch it
without it you didn't have to worry
about breaking your dirt or anything you
just used to went to town yeah I'll put
the stuff in years it's easier I could
never seen the memes they shouldn't
there wasn't good news I just thought
however almost like this are you doing
more like yet all right but we did it
the good way yeah but did you see ours
though how good it was so what are we
supposed to do next it's like what we'll
see Ken we'll see okay well me okay cuz
I'll see more blocks out here I mean
technically we can make infinite blocks
now so there has to be some other
mechanic to it right all right well I
mean don't we just after we get the
cobblestone you're pretty much this
guy's survivor right it's gotta use what
we have I don't know what's the point of
Skyblock really we've already beaten it
I miss our cobblestone generator so much
you can never recreate art that's a
problem all right we're good
bing-bing-bing-bing whoa I know how you
and bridges are don't start with
something else
geez hey hey stop stop right there
criminal criminal scum no screaming bong
Bing you got to do the that one okay
cool
we made it I put bucket there wait so we
have obsidian that means we have to go
to the nether realm next eventually yeah
that's oh that's awesome
there's a whole lesson right
okay so that means we need flint and
steel
what are we get how are we gonna get Wow
look first off how are we gonna survive
but I need to eat something eventually
I'm gonna die eat me oh well we have
character we have a character so we can
make a cactus spawn Hey Oh actually we
have melon we can make melon spawn oh so
now it's going to go grab like all the
dirt from over there right okay so I
have melon melon and then I plant
Madeline but then I have to make it oh
my god this is awesome
we need to like dig up all the dirt
right in like an hour I really shouldn't
have wasted all the way not only would
we ask okay give me one I got one I got
one
it's gonna live right here kid see we
can we use the one water that we have to
make like a infinite water pool are you
able to do that out of just one block of
water no you need for you can I make
make like like I don't know like two
spots and like put it down and pick it
up and put it down the other spot real
quick no you can't man sucks so does
your you and your no sorry okay be rude
how do I make I got it somehow I got it
okay cool I don't know why I made it in
stone what a waste
okay so but I'm gonna say is we got this
whole block here there's like three down
of dads okay so now we plan to Medellin
anyway well just say yes spread this
dirty out here right oh wait this is not
a melon gross dang it were you waiting
to me well we have all this dirt beneath
us we're not using we need to spread all
this out right so you're like dig down
and get it all damn your big brain okay
because I have to say before you hear me
I am spread out spread a problem I have
an idea we should spread out as much as
possible
oh good thinking yeah
yeah so how deep this is go three
there's a mmmm I don't know how we get
the very bottom pieces though without
them falling off maybe do everything
it's getting bigger I like it yeah yeah
I like what he gets bigger wait I can't
we're playing minecraft minecraft sake
ah just play we need to pick the lava
back up so we can dig around and I don't
know is the answer when will you have to
use our big brains magnet then do we
have to like oh dang it I lost one sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh my goodness your mom okay we're gonna
it's over playthrough over
no I'm worried about more trees don't
worry I got you more tree yeah you know
if we started planting trees then we
would actually have like epic trees
right now but no do we want to let me
such a pain to get enough cobblestone
and go under this so we don't drop any
and make the most of our space that we
have yeah we are moving everything from
the bottom up we just move everything
from the top down so that way we don't
worry about the bottom blocks falling
into the void now that's a bigger brain
yeah I think it's too late for that now
though we should know that before a
cobblestone generator will work out with
it what if we make cobblestones well we
still need turn the darkness for the
farming if we make cobblestone I don't
have a pick anymore since that not me
off oh oh the water Oh garsh
I think we have some good space yeah
last night we party started perfect or
anything gamers but do it pro gameplay
wait retching how the Frick did we get
flint and steel ah I see a question big
brain big yeah we use the lava to open
the nether or maybe it's like in the if
I go dig through the sand blue I already
have obsidian so I don't know oh yeah
maybe there's something in the sand
that's a good idea yeah big brain I need
more trees come on
I appreciate
[Laughter]
yeah I've dug down and then bid 100 you
find anything
don't look out there what what happened
oh you see the island at all okay okay
this is another test 11 the chest is
still there we don't need to win well
what about our cactus okay don't touch
the sand because it'll all fall for some
reason I'm concede really okay give me
the pumpkin Hey yeah just grab it do we
need the sand though I don't know I'm
sorry I didn't know you freaked up and I
never forgive Africa fer I just realize
we can't actually probably build
downwards like you said look I'm doing
it I'm doing it can you grab my block
give it back I'll call the cops
my bad sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry
my best forgive is not an excuse I'll
yell as many times as I want all right
okay we are maximizing our efforts yeah
I'd be careful this block right here if
you want to get unless you want to get a
lavage to pick the lava back up
something get the mm-hmm then we can't
put it under there we have to leave
these here leave those little fritters
ah I mean I made up see I just I tell
you this we're really gonna cure like
we're just focused on you know just
doing the stuff that's so much on what
we're actually saying to each other uh
so if I if I pull this one out it'll
make the water go everywhere
I'm just I'm just worried that we're
gonna need that stand for something how
do we get the yeah well you should have
thought about that before you find it it
was gonna fall because I took two boxes
Sam I didn't I didn't think this island
was gonna fall listen to yourself who
thinks the hallways gonna fall everyone
who knows
minecraft oh just like I just like I try
to tell you how to make a cobblestone
cobblestone whatever generator for three
years no one listens oh here we are
oh my god I can't believe you you tried
to kill me I guess if you get hungry
just follow from da
Oh ever need to make melons you're
making the water go everywhere look at
you that's what she said why would you
say that
I don't know why this tree not grow why
does the grass not come Bank oh god I
feel the Commons can they're coming back
I think I can feel people typing right
now no oh do you have your pickaxe still
I think I put it here okay great threw
me off the edge I don't have anything
and then yeah we'll get some more sticks
here oh dude if we put it here it
actually work no no it doesn't work at
all can your homies get some more
saplings
but why hey I called a block good meat
didn't get me me me so good play
Minecraft use me small me make sand off
all whoo whoo
did you get any more trees no we
actually just have one dream one tree
it's that's is it grow gotta pray that
this one actually gives us more we're
gonna rat tree real fast
oh my god I'm so confused what is
happening I don't know this should be
turning this should be turning epic you
got a hoe it did you know it okay plant
pumpkin here in the middle okay oh I'm
king Megara I had more than just that
one now that's all we had but a will
grow don't worry it's the next that we
go like in another all right
ah don't further no I don't see I don't
see anything
what are you sand for you can make glass
with sin well yeah we need glass maybe I
just okay
I'm not here what is your big brain tell
you can my big brain tells me let's see
I hope not really usage we can make it a
TNT gunpowder sandstone glass look at
our beautiful building my god no-one's
ever progress this hard a falling block
again I don't think it matters
you hear that gamers ken thinks the sand
doesn't matter
Oh soon as you got a big youtube please
go ahead and throw this off on me
because when it does matter BIC shut up
you stop it alright now we progress
because I'm I don't know what else good
this point oh maybe we can lit the oh I
got it I got it I got it Ken big brain
don't don't look up anything big brain
big brain
alright I got it I got it lava the lava
would lit dead portal let me let me just
stop you right there yeah we're on to
about 15 minutes ago and I say hey do we
gotta use the lava well do it where do
we build the portal vein ah here well
can ya we could be we we got play a
cobblestone we can do it anywhere right
we don't use cobblestone wob
between how much does it take you get
tin but wait do we do you think cuz oh
god my brain my big brain okay fine okay
we put it here the only reason I'm
hesitant is because you're supposed to
be the minecraft pro I am thanks bro you
think I'm pro I mean you played a lot
more than I have lately that's for damn
sure
no no no I play very this is gonna be a
portal
I'm saving us money Ken I couldn't
possibly understand if I got you yeah
yeah bro that's right I am yeah wait how
many blocks you got left
Frick yeah only cowards build obsidians
with rui hurry
okay so you only like pickup the LOB and
like throw it over there in there or
something yeah we're gonna we're gonna
make the love of throw out over there
okay I will be the lava boy you I was
just gonna say you are the designated
lover boy oh I'm glad you had that idea
I'm so excited okay it's lava time damn
I'm so smart for thinking about that we
should use the lava yeah you're like
just a genius and it's that part out
where I said it where do I just throw it
in here yeah yeah yeah don't drop the
bucket I just I just I all right attempt
to attempt to what a great that day you
had okay
maybe needs to flow from a higher spot
like this pumpkin the pumpkin the
pumpkin
shave the pumpkin oh it's so tiny
did you know you put it work did he work
oh it worked
look yeah you can go go cuz I okay epic
time enjoy what is this do we make a
different block how do we lit the portal
this is hot this surely has to be how
the forefathers did it of Minecraft I
got it you drop it here what the Frick
how are you doing we can't even get the
tree to grow we can't get the tree to
grow we can't get the portal open the
sand thing out there fell Oh our
pumpkins watered wait it's not getting
hydrated here is it hard rain in the
can't tell I don't think it is I think
this game is buggy and I don't like it
anymore this do you think you need the
cactus or something what the heck we'll
use a cactus I'll ever talk back about
cactus
alright wait I actually haven't good
stuff well now I can die when you forget
to write your last will if you if you
look up Skyblock there's like a list of
challenges it's like stuff to do like
stuff to challenge yourself to do
because this cow block is literally just
you know the two blocks that's it
everything else is just gonna make it on
your own right so there's no more
islands I don't think so
I think that's it they just get too and
then they're like good luck if you get
to the second island so you can get food
and actually survive then you spread the
dirt out and then from there you're just
like you're just surviving until you can
go to the nether and do whatever in
there but how would you go to the nether
I don't know that's I don't know how you
do it oh I got it Oh big brain big brain
big brain oh my god
big brain big brain I'm so excited about
that oh you're gonna burn the wood yeah
yeah yeah oh wow that is huge brain
how did your brain get so big minecraft
what pop rock five right brain food are
you are you eating the big brain food
thank you are you eating the G fuel
straight up and ready there actually do
you feel alright great let's do it I'm
doing ready I'm going lit how do I lit
it then without it like just
disappearing uh I mean yeah but it was a
mob but you know just put it next to it
little love tap and it work it's just I
do not is this wood way I think you have
to wait for like a lava flip to hit the
thing really yeah big brain I guess one
nope oh it's flipping yeah yeah it's get
away nothing's working
the seeds grow grow grow do we have to
like but nothing's happening what you
read or something no sides can't explain
this I think we need a different method
yeah I think it's gonna work right okay
I needs to go like like the lava needs
to like go what are you doing what is
this like it needs to go help me my
brain I want to alarm you eating what
melon grew melons gone no what did you
do well I definitely didn't do that and
look down and it was gone your big
brains of the next level right I have no
idea what's going on are you just trying
to get this small brains don't talk to
big brains oh dang it
amazing this is a good idea though 10
just watch I am I'm watching let's see
it
I mean at this point we're pretty much
gonna die yeah I can no don't speak like
that we ice keep turning back in the ice
it's not water anymore
what is happening alright we have a
problem Kim it's a really big problem
yeah okay I'll try and explain it for a
small brain okay okay play a week the
Lama needs to flow on this level we
built that I built him sitting him too
too far down so we need to lower
everything and the only way to do that
is if I jump off and I place the block
while falling big brain why don't we
just like make some water go over the
edge lights freakin I heard that one big
brain yeah
oh so big very nice okay all right
there's hope in the world okay so now
the Louisville will flow here the thing
will be here it will be burning Oh a big
where's the llama what where's the llama
you had it off the edge of the lobbyists
game so no that big brain wait don't
burn me alive what what is today's we
have to start over it
because we're just running ahead of
everything are you kidding me you need
to do you need to move the lava I don't
know is it's flowing how do you do it
why is it flowing it is flowing
underneath how the Frick is it's not
burning its magic wood if if you just
throw the LOB on top of the wood will it
work or will it just disappear
burn what is this wood made out of huh
big break okay big brain though the
bucket down or something before you die
with it I have a big brain right now
yeah I'm gonna finish to eat more lava
means more flipper dippers right
you go try me more lava more lava we may
use it here we should probably protect
little tree I mean we already lost melon
oh sorry
okay well eventually something should
catch on fire right yeah this is this is
big oh I see it oh that was close well
place more wood so that it's more likely
to catch on fire right are you okay yeah
I'm fine
okay so ice I put the random and then
once they're on fire we'll connect them
Christian mark everything my big brain
tells me is that kind of like what you
did like dig the two out and then just
put
would over the top of it and then just
wait Ritz I like flip up and hit it burn
that makes sense mm-hmm like where I am
w habla and then the blocks directly
above it the wood oh that hit it on it
are you kidding me I'm just burning they
look like I'm burning to you okay I have
a new idea I don't feel so good I have a
big brain it-- okay cuz go in the would
go on the would gonna get you're fine go
jump on the wood bird birds my body Oh
sad just burn but you are burning white
haha okay new idea we burn tree that's
crazy
why does tree not grow we did bone meal
for tree I guess you know we could get
bone meal if we actually had like enough
surface area to her bad gas bond that we
could like the bad guys dropped for it
oh my god I have a big brain idea boy
bad guys can only spawn when there is no
when there's light darkness so we should
make a platform over there and cover it
with from light so get brain so they oh
my god big brain let's do it yeah yeah
that's big brain thinking big brain
third good I have the water here so we
need to make a cobblestone generator my
god yeah you see how big this lavas
right now we can make all the
cobblestone oh it works yeah nice
perfect right there that's the sweet
spot
Betty's back baby baby's back if you
like get down here in the water and
catch it all oh my god this is great
eventually we're gonna run out of tools
a big rain it will catch on fire when
we're not looking it's like milk it only
burns when you're not looking what what
did you say to me
I can't wait for all the Minecraft kids
with small brains to tell us what we're
doing wrong yeah small brain it's gonna
be something like you know you got to
put the lava this way to make it burn or
something
wait why I don't know like water and
lava are just weird okay nobody
understands how they work like magnets
except big brain people under this jump
in the water don't lose all the
cobblestone please put it down nobody
there what are you doing well what else
don't muscle to put it down it you'll be
a jump off and like do it magical anyway
I just down here so we can start like
building downward because you know Kenta
what we just need to kill them they
spawn first
yeah but monsters can't spawn their BIOS
the point was that we build it on the
other side you know how I supposed to
build it under build that only island
built like a if it needs to be a 5 by 5
squared I know here's them on the island
the other Island no I was not there it
doesn't exist
we'll make one I just need 10 blocks
give me a block so I can start jumping
off and making it you know or you know
it can it's becoming more and more clear
throughout this playthrough that you're
not actually big brain are you serious
are you are you are you serious right
now I'll say it I'll say it then I'll
say oh we need 50 cobblestone my brain
just made out
that's quick math exit my brain is
pretty small cuttings build up yeah I'm
an idiot the whole time like I need to
build down I have to build down but
don't talk to me okay
be great okay we need safety table
stones dude and we're running out of
pickaxes no all you have to do run
through the lava and and hit their water
but you picked the water up oh wait no
you put it back down didn't I can see
yeah big brain candy to build me a
bridge because I can't lose the bucket
can I build you a bridge he says Jesus
Christ you jump to that thanks babe we
do the water just so we can make blocks
quicker over there
yeah the colorful generator moving the
cobblestone generator is mobile God tree
doesn't grow because maybe you're
treating tree like garbage
I love tree I love I want to see this
generator you're gonna make don't mess
up our one block of water cuz I get back
I wall run Ken oh stop it before it's
too strong you get more lava
oh no you Pig you live again you want
some dude look how much we made oh no no
wait wait wait
it's the water it's all we have now I
don't think you even have that long run
Oh tree will never grow this is sky blog
it's the best
pro-gamers here she oniy how it's done
yeah let's just read there it's no
problem
oh yeah dare dare we come back in the
future to try to finish this smash like
if you wanna stay for more big brains
smash like if you have a big brain then
we'll see you next time
oh please god no what you never played
super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]